[Music]
hello everyone welcome to our session
for understanding the use cases of
unstructured data in healthcare my name
is Javed Khan and I'm director of
knowledge management and data services
at Rush University Medical Center
my primary role at Rush is to store
analyze and provide insights to the
hospital or hospital system I have about
a dozen awesome data engineers and data
scientists who work with my team and
that's what we do for a living
store data and analyze data for
healthcare insights I welcome you on
behalf of both of my co-presenters here
Davey want to introduce yes my name is
David Patterson I'm a senior principal
with maven we're a premier partner of
Google we've been working with Jawad and
his team for the past six to seven
months so excited to talk to you guys
today hi everyone and I my name is Vasu
Gupta I am a customer engineer with
Google and I've been working with the
rush and may even be a team on on some
of the UC interesting use cases that we
are doing it rush just kind of one
housekeeping item before we get started
we do have a Dory link that's really a
link on your app to allow you to submit
questions any time during the
presentation we'll have a Q&A for ten
minutes at the end so it would be great
if you can submit your questions as
you're thinking about it during the
presentation or at the end you can also
come up and speak it to the mic as well
great thank you all right like I said
the idea of this session was to
primarily share with all of you what do
we do with unstructured data in relation
specifically to the EHR the electronic
health records how much instructor we
collect and what do we do with the
unstructured data how do we store the
unstructured data how do we retrieve the
unstructured data and what type of
analysis we do provide that was the idea
of this session but before we get there
let me share a few things about rush you
never see them
called center we are a very historical
Institute in Chicago anybody from
Chicago in the crowd here there you go
so a few folks here you all may know
about rush we are three hospitals one
out in Copley one in Russia Oak Park and
one right in West Sider downtown we have
more than 30 plus outpatient clinics we
are a rest University for medical school
we are 5'4 time actually magnet nursing
school all you need to know what Rush is
available on the website you can go find
out more but this slide actually talks
about what Russia is doing and how we
are at the forefront of making an effort
at least to transform healthcare Russia
was since our CIO dr. Joffe group joined
us two years ago we were the first
institution to implement a full closed
cycle social determinants of health we
are very engaged with the community
where we are today and we have a system
where now people coming in into our
Center are screened for social
determinants we refer them to
electronically to a source and the data
flows back into the EMR so first
institution that did a full lifecycle of
social determinants of health rush is
like I said we are first institution to
implement managing meds through a mobile
application nurse documentation we were
the first institution to receive or one
of the three institutions to receive a
state 7 in analytics and goes it's
pretty busy slide but the idea was
essentially to show what we were doing
like I said to transform healthcare even
an institution like us having said that
has or continuously is struggling with
what do we do with the data specifically
with the unstructured data and is
anybody in the audience here who works
in the healthcare specifically hurt care
vertical there are a few people over
there quite a few people great good how
many of you are like in the provider
space in the hospital space got it
beautiful so there a few the if you look
behind if you look under the hood of
what's in a in a hospital system or
specifically behind electronic health
record
it is this it's thousands of tables a
lot of data mostly highly normalized
very hard to find any one-to-one
relationships and then when you compound
that with a problem like this where
there is data everywhere else in fact
only about I would say 20 30 % of the
data that we analyze and store comes
from the electronic health record but
there lies everywhere else it's outside
the EMR s in our ERP systems in our
networking systems and believe it or not
all the data is still relevant to health
care it is still relevant to how we
provide care to our patients so we are
very interested in putting the data
together putting a data in a common
platform and trying to solve healthcare
problems with the data in short
healthcare data is classic big data it
comes from all different angles it has
veracity does velocity and you name it
so what are we doing with it
specifically like I said the idea of
this presentation was to talk about
unstructured data and what are we doing
with unstructured data as you may know
any because people specifically you're
in health care and people who are
specially working in the hospital field
you may know that out of box we don't
necessarily have solutions to easily
analyze healthcare data EHR doesn't come
with NLP so to say right we would have
to implement that we would have to
extract the data we would have to manage
the data and implement a solution that
that does analyze unstructured data
doctors like to type notes in a typical
EHR implementation there are more than
100 cuss notes their progress knows
their pathology nodes their nurses knows
their notes everywhere in fact even in a
most simple statement like a nurse would
be typing and saying there's this person
oh I receive a dog like I'm saying their
salary is getting drug from a friend
when when you get that medication
ontology and you understand what those
drugs are and how do they mine up to the
patient's problems it's a very difficult
problem to solve because those insights
are not readily available so what do we
do with unstructured data to be able to
solve problem what are we doing today
and it is like I said it is not really
necessarily easy and any solution that
you read about unstructured data our NLP
having done healthcare is mostly still
today living on the research side not
very many implementations or not very
many solutions or products have come on
the commercial side and that's what rush
specifically our team is focused on
doing I have some folks from my team
here who have been living and breathing
NLP and unstructured data for the last
two years guys you want to raise your
hands please accolades to them these are
amazing engineers they have learned so
much about medical ontology
so much about how to understand what
those anthologies are and how they
relate to solving medical problems is
incredible I encourage all of you to
talk to them I am just one person
representing all the work that we have
done over two years with NLP data so in
short it is very difficult to extract
the data it is very difficult to store
the data in a comprehensive solution and
be able to provide solution it is very
very costly in fact like I said we have
spent good two years good two years to
extract the data from an EMR store in a
format that we can understand in a
single platform and be able to analyze
it what does the data look like today an
average provider node specifically if
you look at it is about forty five
kilobytes and we collect about 8.5
million nodes per years if you do two
years our when we started the project
why am i saying two years here is
because when we started this NLP project
in our institution first our focus was
to look at at least two years worth of
notes right historically go back and
extract two years worth of data and
analyze it and see what insights we can
find and sure enough just those two
years were worth of notes were so big
that our data centers couldn't handle it
or we were not able to store it and
process it in a single infrastructure so
we have to look at other solutions to be
able to do that and now because what we
achieved with finding insights and I'm
going to talk about that in a few
minutes with two years worth of data the
institution has asked us now to expand
that search go back to extracting ten
years worth of data and that literally
will end up in petabytes of data it's
really a problem to solve how do we
actually
analyze all the data and be able to
provide meaningful insights for the
institution the use cases that we were
that we specifically started with for
with unstructured data is around adenoma
as adenoma detection is a very important
measure it's a CMS measure it gives our
GI Department like a if if the doctors
for example per patients come in and
they're not screening the patient's
properly in plural ask apiece for colon
cancer it's a big deal it's a measure
that gets measured by the CMS like I
said so we started doing our NLP with
adenoma detection meaning we were
extracting all the pathology and the
provider notes to be able to identify
where the doctors were typing for
adenoma and be able to provide a
dashboard straight up of the data for
them to be able to see we were
successful in providing a use case for
adenoma we're now providers are actively
using a dashboard off of our
unstructured data in real time in memory
to be able to make decisions about which
patients to be called back into the
healthcare or in the clinical pathway to
prevent people from getting colon cancer
so this is a big deal it is a big deal
both from regulatory point of view for
the institution to be compliant of a
specific measure it's a big deal for
patients right because we're in the
business of providing best healthcare
for our patients
the second was about hnp history and
physical for the providers history and
physical is also a regulatory measure so
if for its to be specific about so to
explain what it means for people who may
not know is if I'm going in a surgery
for example and if my history and
physical is not complete in my EHR 48
hours prior to the surgery that surgery
kit needs to be cancelled if the
institution if any institution fails to
do that then it's a bad mark on you you
can get audited and it would be
exception for institution so it we
cannot make that happen and for an
institution of our size with three
different hospitals making sure every
surgery has every student physical
completed manually is a big deal it
actually required a staff of three
nurses to go through
all the history and physical to make
sure it's complete well we were able to
use our NLP engine or AI platform to be
able to comprehend simply identify and
score history and physicals which were
complete and which were not complete and
the guy who did this here at DARPA I
mean I mean this that pun was
instrumental in figuring out a I
solution full end-to-end where we
extract the histories and physicals from
EMR you run it through NLP and we make
sure that the history physically is
complete before we provide again - but
with the end users to be able to recall
either history of physical are completed
before the proviso it's a huge use case
amazingly valuable for the institution
we were able to save time money and
resources for the institution and the
third one last but not the least is
clinical documentation improvement like
I was giving an example of where very
mundane notes can be typed above
medication about health conditions about
comorbidities they're not readily
available unless somebody is able to go
through those notes and extracts those
insights clinical documentation
improvement is very important one to
make sure that the patients we are able
to provide better health care proper
healthcare relevant health care to the
patients and at the same time again it
helps an institution to affect and
address the bottom line that is if you
are in the payer space you know what I'm
talking about if you're in there
insurance pays you know what I'm talking
about if we send a claim for the patient
for the patient's record or the
transaction with our proper
documentation then guess what
it gets denied it gets rejected it gets
delayed so it is extremely important for
us to be able to make sure that the
clinical documentation improvement is in
place and in short of having everything
completed manually we developed a
solution that is 100% based on data
extraction unstructured data to improve
our clinical depression improvement all
the use cases that are talked about
obviously requires both processing the
data in the backend
running through an NLP engine matching
with with unta medical oncology
sometimes general ontology sometimes
very specific to specific service lines
be it cancer being hip and joint whatnot
and on top of that we have to make sure
that we are able to provide the
solutions to the end users to be able to
consume the information that the engine
has provided right without that it
becomes very difficult
and all this are definitely important
problems there but there are really hard
problems we often run into people
vendors who talk about having one
solution in one place and in this to
this day we haven't found it's very very
difficult you always have to put pieces
together to be able to solve the problem
with unstructured data and anybody who's
familiar with working with file system
databases and extracting the data in the
native format storing it it's a
challenge and if I'm doing it on daily
basis to operationalize something it's a
challenge this problems are definitely
not easy to solve but they're very very
important and if anybody in my opinion
is not dealing with health if it
unstructured data that is available in
the institution in any healthcare
institution then we are not looking at
the one of the key components of the
data that we need to analyze so that's
the story that that you need to take
away from today is that if you are not
as an institution if you're not tackling
unstructured data then you're leaving a
big piece of puzzle behind it is very
very important that an institution like
ours who are primarily responsible
providing best health care should 100%
look to solve unstructured data analyze
it solve it and provide it as a as a
solution for the institutions having
said that the challenges are unlimited
there is many more use cases that can be
done even today after what we have done
for fast three years we still have
disjoint datasets there is unstructured
data like I said in our ERP s that need
to be brought back that will be consumed
in all types of solutions and we are
slowly and definitely working towards
solving those problems this slide
specifically was to help you understand
what it is and show you how we have
achieved some of those use cases what we
wanted to do what we have learned it
definitely to to be able to solve or put
together a solution using unstructured
data you have to make sure that we are
able to solve the problem one by
collaboration internally and externally
with the partners and the people within
the resources we have to make sure that
we are able to like I said provide know
to the end users this is intuitive for
them to be able to consume the data and
be able to work with the data that we
are provided and
insights how do they do interventions
with the data that we are providing what
actions are able located behave they are
able to take with the data we are
providing these things are definitely
not or cannot be isolated or siloed you
have to put that together as you're
thinking to these problems
the second is scale how do we scale this
problem how do we like I was saying go
from 2 years to 10 years and how do we
do it in a cost-effective fashion right
and single source of truth this is
continuous to be a problem we have tried
so many different solutions and I can
speak to you very transparently that
when we first started on this journey
two years ago for five months within the
project we failed we miserably failed
because we were not able to properly
implement a solution that was cost
effective the cost of the cost that were
incurring for storing and processing the
data was growing significantly there was
a question about why not do it and in
houses supposed to do it in cloud there
were so many different problems that we
had to solve so it's definitely worth
trying something failing early and
fixing it as you go about that's the
lesson that we that we learned and
wanted to share with you what now so
what do we do like I said we want to go
into the space of pop health we want to
be able to do a lot of KPI performance
improvement using this data we have a
lot of neural cases that we want to
implement as we move to move forward
maybe this is time for us to talk about
how we are partnering with Google and
maven wave to sort of solve this problem
like I said unstructured data obviously
is very important to solve but it is not
a you cannot solve that before all
actually also matting that with the
structured data and how we are using or
leveraging TCP today I think also we'll
talk about that Russell Hantz yes thanks
Jerrod
so drug hit on kind of a business
problem that we were really looking at
it rushed and really kind of this unique
problem of melding the unstructured data
with structured data what I'm gonna talk
a little bit about is really how Google
Cloud healthcare and the products and
solutions that we offer was instrumental
in making this kind of business problem
and solving this business problem
and really the focus of my presence or
this focus of my part of the
presentation really be on the cloud
healthcare API and the clinical data
warehouse which were two of the unique
products that were critical and
integrals to really building all this
end-to-end pipeline for solving the
business problem and and click cloud
healthcare API being that key mechanism
for ingesting and storing and analyzing
of the data and then clinical data
warehouse as you look at different
sources and all these disparate data
formats coming together how you really
kind of put out that together and really
build this notion of a clinical data
warehouse sitting on top of something
like bigquery for the petabytes amount
of data that you're looking to handle so
so what is the cloud healthcare API so
it's a solution that's being built by
the cloud healthcare team that really
speaks understands talks the healthcare
specific vernacular and healthcare
specific language it's really meant to
accelerate your ingestion of your data
your storage of the data the analysis of
the data specific to healthcare in its
current state right now it supports
DICOM hl7 v2 and fire which stands for
fast healthcare interoperable resources
answers and so many people in the crowd
that are from the healthcare industry
this should not be a surprise and if you
look at sort of the trend within the
healthcare industry and the fact that
there's so many disparate data formats
there's there's kind of a move in the
industry in healthcare to really
standardize to adopting fires that gold
standard but like I said the healthcare
API supports all these different three
data types in its native form within the
healthcare API what does the healthcare
API comprise off in a nutshell so really
I kind of boil it down to three main
components at the center of it all is
really a secure high performant
repository that exists for DICOM hl7 -
and fire so there's a fire store in hl7
we to store and a DICOM store that
exists within the healthcare API and
then wrapped around that repositories is
a series of both admin and
access api's they're compliant with
healthcare data standards and really
allow you to talk that healthcare
specific language and access that data
that's sitting in those stores and then
third is really a suite of integrations
and capability that allow you to do the
most with your healthcare data so a
combination of the repositories the API
is and the integrations whether it be
integrations to your systems that is
ingesting the data or or integrations
outside to external applications to send
the data out healthcare API provides
those capabilities and that's why it's a
unique and compelling product and also
why it was critical in kind of solving
this problem of ingesting this
unstructured data which in this case for
rush was within fire messages that we
ingested from the different EMR systems
so if you kind of look at the clinical
data mapping workflow in its kind of
entirety the data like I said it could
be in different formats it can be at hl7
be to fire it can also be in some of the
other non-standard formats like CSV XML
so and so forth so as you're looking to
ingest these data across from different
systems in different formats and really
trying to build this sort of central
place and storing that data you kind of
go to the healthcare API and and like I
said there's a fire store within the
healthcare API that allows you to
capture that data so there's like a
middle transformation layer right so
you've got all these different sources
and especially if you're looking at
doing cross modality analysis across the
different data sources that
transformation layer you know to convert
hl7 to fire or CSV to fire really
allowing that and capturing that data in
something like a fire stores and that's
something that cloud health KPI does
really well and then once that data is
there in the cloud healthcare API in
that fire store the data can be exposed
to external applications so an example
could be an application sitting on top
of App Engine or even the data could be
exposed as API is through something like
Apogee and so and so forth so that data
again can be exposed to external
applications and then also if you're
looking at again
melding that unstructured and structured
data if you want that structured
analysis of that data in this case you
know we had notes that we were ingesting
Aspire messages and we wanted to create
a schema that was standard for analysis
the data can also be stored in something
like bigquery or even if you want to do
machine learning models on top of the
data then really using a product like
cloud ml engine to do some of that
machine learning so all in all if you
kind of look at that end-to-end workflow
from the ingestion to the
standardization to really exposing the
data in different ways that's something
that we built as the common architecture
pattern when we were working with rush
one of the other capabilities that the
healthcare API provides is the ability
to react to data near real-time and what
I mean by that is there's a strong
integration between the cloud healthcare
API and cloud pub/sub which is our
real-time messaging in in on streaming
service and anytime a data lands in the
firestore of the DICOM store it
essentially sends a notification message
to pub/sub and that could be a trigger
for different things that you do
downstream again whether it be certain
rendering to certain applications or
maybe a cloud functions routine that in
turn you know executes some machine
learning model the output of which can
then be integrated back into your
external application so this this this
kind of powerful notion of being able to
react to data real time to think about
real time inferences as you start
building your machine learning models is
a really compelling story with the
healthcare API another capability that
is provided the ability to be identify
your fire and DICOM resources so then
the cloud healthcare API there's a D
idn't if I call that you can make and
depending on the attributes that you
specify you can configure that and it
will D identify those specific
attributes and create essentially
another version of your data set or
store and capture that within you know
another fire store a DICOM store and so
and so forth and this is applicable
again even on the icon images the fire
resources and so on
and then last but not least you know
another key capability is the ability to
export this fire and icon metadata to
bigquery so like again coming back to
John's point the the notion or really
being able to analyze this unstructured
data and make sense of it and you know
capturing it in something like bigquery
can be extremely powerful one of the
things that's not on here but that's
something that's being released really
soon is cloud healthcare API is also
going to be able to support real-time
streaming of data to bigquery so that's
also coming so you know in the future
essentially as the data is coming as a
health care API without this export it
export call you the data can be streamed
into bigquery directly so again in kind
of in summary this card healthcare API
was central or core to building this
pipeline and ingesting these fire leaves
unstructured data in the clinical notes
embedded in the fire messages for our
solution but kind of shifting gears a
little bit and talking more on the
structured data side again if you think
about this going back to this idea that
you have data coming from different
sources and different formats both you
know historical data and incremental
data you want to map it to some sort of
a common data model right there's a lot
of different data models that exist
within the healthcare industry so
thinking about kind of your own mob data
model see this for even a consistent and
structured fire schema that again is
that middle layer the mapping and
transformation layer that becomes
critical so how do I map hl7 to fire or
how do I map CSV to fire so one of the
other products that the Google health
team is investing heavily in is really
building this mapping and transformation
layer to make this clinical data
warehouse solution you know really
effective and and really efficient and
the idea behind that is gonna be
building of a mapping and a
configuration tool that allows you to
map between different data formats and
provide provides you this UI and Bui
like interface to allow you to map
between different formats and we're
interjecting that layer with a lot of
machine learning capability so how does
that mapping layer
become smarter over time as you look to
transform and build these target schemas
and build this notion of a clinical data
warehouse on bigquery and kind of taking
it one level further you know if you
think about you know what you really
want to do from you've got all these
different sources you've got all these
different types of data how do I really
do cross modality analysis how do I
blend for instance maybe you know
genomics data in the future to the data
that's coming from fire hl7 DICOM so and
so forth so if again thinking about the
pipeline ingesting the data from EHR
systems or your PAC systems into the
healthcare I specific stores capturing
that data in bigquery performing certain
transforms and different analytics on it
and really creating these ready to
consume schemas which could be again all
mops custom-made schemas fire schemas so
and so forth and having it to the end
user for different analytics and
visualization use cases is really our
kind of vision for this cross modality
analysis and really this ability to
build this clinical data warehouse and
bigquery so I'll just wrap up by saying
that again cloud healthcare API and the
clinical data warehouse were key
healthcare products and solutions that
we kind of considered as we were
building this architecture and I'm gonna
hand it over today who's going to talk
about the end-to-end solution
architecture
thank you sue
all right so I get to hopefully bring
some of the solution together yeah and
Link the healthcare API back to the
message and challenges that we were
having at rush so what I want to show
you is how we can combine the healthcare
API along with a natural language
processing engine running on GCP to
unlock key healthcare use cases that
Jawad would referred to that includes
document integrity integrity checking
clinical decision support public health
records and disease transit before I get
to the solution I want to give you our
share with you the journey that maven
wave and rush has been on when maven
wave works with clients we typically
recommend four phases for moving
workloads to GCP the first one is assess
so this is when you're prototyping
you're experimenting and really trying
to figure out if GCP is the right fit
for your solution the second is planning
this is setting up infrastructure
getting project organized setting up
billing and most importantly picking
your first work load moving on to
deployment this is implementation
migration of the workload and finally
operationalizing which is standing up a
program with your kind of future work
backlog key throughout this process is
too tightly aligned scope to business
value and security needs rather than
trying to build the perfect technology
platform really kind of quickly get
deliver business value to kind of build
credibility in the organization so where
we're at with rush we are through the
first deployment and working with them
to define future workloads that Jawad
will talk through here in a little bit
all right so let's get on to document
coding bases so back to what Javad was
referring to in terms of kind of getting
structure out of unstructured patient
documents so what are the basic building
blocks
the first one is applying core NLP and
this is kind of the standard
technologies that are used across
natural language technologies but that
includes part parts of speech
extraction contacts negation detection
and most importantly for this use case
is the named entity recognition that's a
challenge in in medical or clinical
notes which makes the second step
critical which is applying medical
vocabularies and these are vocabularies
that are curated by international health
organizations the two that we used in
this solution was sno-med CT that
includes three hundred thousand coded
medical concepts including diagnosis
clinical findings body structures and
observations
the second is rxnorm which is geared
towards pharmaceuticals and links to
common drug vocabularies so the third
building block is taking our coded
documents and like Vasu is mentioning
getting them stored in a clinical data
warehouse so let's look at an example of
what what this looks like here you can
see the precise coatings that have been
extracted from a fragment of a clinical
narrative and it's these precise
coatings that really form the foundation
for cross patient analytics alright so
in terms of our solution approach first
we went out to land raw unstructured
patient data in the healthcare fire
store so we didn't use a great amount of
the data structures available in the API
but we did get a lot of acceleration
just from using and not having to
redefine a schema as we're moving raw
data from the EMR into Google second
were the security controls that were
already in place second step was
established an auto scaling medical NLP
micro service platform we did that on
kubernetes engine third was leveraging
data flow and beam pipelines for data
orchestration and then finally creating
a clinical data warehouse in bigquery
so establishing the NLP core fortunately
there's been a lot of good work
I think Jawad mentioned in the research
hospitals research organizations around
this problem set so we were able to use
two open source technology see takes and
quick um less and then augment that with
some custom rule-based NLP for rush the
bad news is that some of these
technologies have evolved over the
course of a decade or more so you know
they're monolithic they had varied
support for api's so the second step was
to modernize and normalize those
applications so we performed some
optimizations and threading and around
performance and then we implemented web
friendly api is in json and g RPC
finally container izing and then moving
to kubernetes engine and this was this
was key to kind of providing that kind
of auto scaling capability and cost
control that that rush was looking for
so putting it all together so working
from the left we sourced unstructured
patient records from the EMR we landed
them in the healthcare api we leverage
some of the event triggering that Vasu
mentioned to trigger real-time data
flows to then apply the NLP coding and
finally storing that in a scalable data
warehouse built on bigquery and that
sets us up nicely for future ml
workloads as well as descriptive
analytics and data exploration some
future workloads we plan to take imaging
data from the PAC system DICOM files and
move them to the healthcare healthcare
API claims data and ERP also to kind of
round out operations and and and kind of
do cross analytics with that patient
data here's a different view of the same
architecture we can see EMR some of the
future data sources at rush patient data
storage and fire filtering and parsing
and data flow we had a medical NLP on
kubernetes engine finally moving that
to a clinical data warehouse on on big
group alright I think I'm gonna hand it
back over to Jawad for some takeaways
and roadmap items they thank you Dave
so like wasu and Dave mentioned we
started with just looking at
unstructured data meaning we were
specifically focusing on just the notes
that we were extracting but there are
several modalities that we are now
starting to work on because we have
confidence the architecture seems to be
pretty stable and I think they're ready
to expand to other modalities and the
first thing they're going to look at is
like they've talked about is to connect
our PAC server to the to the GCP
environment and be able to directly
query the data from the PAC server into
a DICOM store and then have machine
learning models run on that imaging the
second use case is to do um it's very
similar to that server but more focus on
the cancer side - I actually do some
mammograms and there is a solution
already out there that we use today
which is on Prem to do a real-time ai on
a mammogram so if somebody comes in for
a mammogram the image gets in the PAC
server and we immediately run it through
a ml model to sort of annotate it to see
if it is positive negative for for
breast cancer right those kisses are
running today on Prem today but it's
very isolated to just mammograms when we
are expanding it to other imaging
solutions and the idea is to be able to
do that over the cloud because obviously
we would have to scale for other use
cases the third is our clinical day
tomorrow today is completely in our data
centers in our on Prem data centers both
the both the transaction or operational
data bases the data warehouses are all
within the within our data centers today
and our unstructured or advanced
analytics all happening in cloud so
there is a sort of a disconnect every
time we have to bring clinical data to
be able to correlate with our advanced
analytic solutions we are having to
either batch this queries back into the
cloud or bring some of the unstructured
data that we have now converted into
structured data down
into our where the warehouses are and be
able to do analytics but ideally there
is I think the time is right for us to
be able to look at those data structures
and data warehousing solutions very
carefully now and we are seriously
giving it a very hard look to see if we
can implement a common clinical data
model that supports both advanced
analytics and our bi solutions in cloud
type of structure there is there are not
many very well design clinical data
models that are out there we use I don't
know if you guys are familiar with OMA
we use OMA pass the data model for some
of the use cases but it doesn't
necessarily support outside of just
transactions right so we have other
clinical use cases that we want to
expand the data models to and we really
want a true representation of a clinical
data model looks like including the
patient finances including corporate
finances and including or clinical
outcomes we are very closely looking at
like I said to move that into our GC or
bigquery type of environment to be able
to leverage both structure and
unstructured data last but not the least
it is of high interest I mean it's one
of the institutional priorities to be
able to develop a search solution today
it is very difficult to search within
the EHR electronic health records you
can probably do a search even with the
third-party solution across the patient
charts or maybe just you know looking at
the patient chart vertically you are
able to search for comorbidities and
some of the diseases that you're looking
for specifically but doing across the
EMR is a bit not there yet so the
provider is not able to look his or her
and panel meant in a very comprehensive
way to be able to identify solutions and
then to make it more complex what if you
have more than one EHR how are you then
able to search across all the EHRs if
the provider is seeing a patient say for
example at our satellite location in a
different HR and the POIs turn off comes
back to the hospital as an attendee he
has this patient year he's not able to
really search for the comprehensively
across all systems so the idea is to
again bring all this data together in a
chronic in a common clinical data model
have unstructured data insights
available in a single place where we can
do searches we are we have a name for it
we are calling a single big query that
we want to
as part of the EHR solution
[Music]